Let's look at this
rocket sled here.
It's gone on in the snow,
but it wants to stop.
There are two little
devices mounted on the sled,
and they can eject gas.
And so the forward one
is used to eject gas
to make the sled stop.
We want to derive a relation
for the differential
between the speed of the
sled and the differential
of the mass of the rocket sled.
But before we do that
with a rocket equation,
we need to actually
consider what
else we know about this system.
Well, we know that the
dry mass has a mass of m0.
The fuel mass is
given also as m0.
And we know that, at time of t
equals 0, the speed of the sled
is v0.
We also know that, at a
later time, t plus delta t,
we have the sled here whose
mass is now m of t plus delta t.
And we have this low mass
parcel that has been ejected,
so the gas.
And that has the mass of delta
mf, so the mass of the fuel.
We furthermore know that,
relative to the sled,
this little gas parcel
is moving with a speed u.
The rocket equation says that
my force-- my external force--
has two terms.
We have the mass of the
rocket times the acceleration
of the sled minus
the differential here
of the mass times the speed u.
And these are
actually all vectors.
And so this describes this
little gas parcel here,
and this one describes
rocket and we
know that v equals v i hat.
i hat is going in the right--
in the direction of motion,
and u equals u i hat.
We also know that no external
forces apply to the sled,
so that's actually 0.
We can then turn this equation.
We can apply all of this.
We will get 0 equals mr
dvr/dt minus dmr/dtu.
We can bring this one
on the other side,
and we end up with the
relationship that we wanted
to obtain-- namely,
an equation that
contains the differentials
of the speed of the rocket,
that sled, and the
differential of the mass.